what people have to remember is that the
object of industrialism wasn't to make
more stuff better and faster it was to
disconnect labour from the value they
created so if I have a shoe factory I
don't want to hire expensive shoe makers
and cobblers in my business I want to go
to the Home Depot parking lot find a
bunch of undocumented aliens and pay
them two cents an hour so I'm gonna
teach them something it's gonna take me
15 minutes to teach them how to nail one
nail into the shoe and then pass it on
to the next guy the person who
understands how this all works is
actually my enemy so you fast forward to
today when we implement digital
technologies we try to do them in ways
that get rid of people we don't want
employees if you need human beings well
then how are you gonna scale up has to
be able to be an algorithm you know the
easy way to think about it is when we
most of our most people's first
interaction with a computer was probably
a telephone answering system now and
sure I understand a company has a human
receptionist that's sitting there you
know she's got a salary she got benefits
she's got a health plan get rid of her
put in a computer so people who call
your company are gonna have to take a
little bit more time to get through all
those menus you're gonna save a lot of
money and it makes you look kind of
high-tech but while you save money
everybody who calls the company now
spends more time going through those
menus you've actually created more work
rather than less you've externalized the
cost of your human receptionist on to
everybody else so then what do they do
well now they all have to get computer
operators because they have to
externalise the cost to everybody else
so we all end up now spending more time
and energy going through those though
going through those menus than we did
when we hired somebody but because we
are so biased against hiring because the
company's stock price will go up if it
can show that it's hired less people we
end up perpetuating that system
so when we implement digital
technologies in order to get people out
of the way in order to get them out of
the company we end up really killing the
only expertise we have if you're using
algorithms and big data to figure out
your next product line rather than
designers what's your competitive
advantage the other companies using that
same data and probably hiring the same
big data analytics company to figure out
the future trends so now you've been
turned into a commodity know you've got
a reverse in a digital age what you want
is the most qualified people you can
find so that your business actually can
differentiate itself from all of the
other automated algorithmic nonsensical
platforms out there what consumers have
to understand is that there's a value
proposition with everything that they
use they have to be able and currently
they can't they have to be able to ask
themselves is this platform creating
value for me or am i creating value for
it or is there an exchange that I'm
aware of and I'm okay with you know do I
want to run my social life on Facebook
is this an exchange that I like do I
like defining myself in that way do I
like these radio buttons do I want to
present myself to the world through this
platform and I am i okay with everything
they know about me
I don't know am i okay with me getting
my news and information through a
newsfeed
that's algorithmically optimized to make
me click on things to narrow and figure
out who I am am i okay
living on a platform that's using past
data about me to advertise and market a
future to me that I haven't yet decided
to go live if they know there's a 70 or
80 percent chance that I might go on a
diet in a month what are they gonna do
they start filling my newsfeed with hey
you're looking kind of fat something's
wrong with you and they're gonna try to
steer me to be more consistent with my
profile to make me a more predictable
and cooperative consumer I guess that's
okay as long as maybe it was a diet and
so they're gonna encourage me to go on
it but
what about the other 20% of people what
about what I might have done instead
what about that unpredictability that
would have made me different from the
next guy
and let me innovate something let me
have a new idea let me have a more
interesting personal anomalous weird
life well maybe I'm ok to surrender that
maybe I want to be more like the rest of
my statistical profile but at least I
should know this at least I should know
that my Google search results are
different from yours
why because Google wants me to do
something Google wants me to be a
certain way Google wants to help me be
the real me but how do they know what
the real me is what's the algorithm
they're using and to what end
you